o sea que una función derivable definida
en el intervalo menos 66 la gráfica de
la derivada que prima se muestra a
continuación
la gráfica de la derivada esta es la
gráfica de la derivada de gm que prima
déjeme subrayarlo porque eso es muy
importante la derivada que prima es esta
que tengo aquí esta es la gráfica no es
la gráfica de ejemplo y nos preguntan
cuál es el valor de x para el punto de
inflexión más a la izquierda de la
gráfica de g ok me preguntan el valor de
x para el punto de inflexión más a la
izquierda de la gráfica define así que
qué te parece si recordamos un poco qué
es lo que pasa en los puntos de
inflexión y vamos a aplicarnos qué es lo
que pasa en g prima heavy prima y bien g
así que para eso déjame hacer una tabla
por aquí voy a tener más o menos algo
así y bueno algo así y voy a fijarme en
el imán aquí tengo a mi prima aquí tengo
prima y aquí tengo a la función original
la segunda derivada la primera derivada
y la función g ok y qué es lo que pasa
cuando tenemos un punto de inflexión
bueno en un punto de inflexión la
segunda derivada cambia de signo es
decir cambia de positivo a negativo o de
negativo a positivo así que consideremos
el primer caso vamos a ver el primer
escenario donde heavy prima va a cambiar
de positiva de positiva positiva a
negativa
de iván y bien si eso es lo que pasa con
heavy prima con la segunda derivada
entonces vamos a pensar qué es lo que
pasa con la primera derivada y con la
función original que es lo que va a
pasar con la primera derivada bueno
recuerda la segunda derivada es la
derivada de la primera derivada entonces
si gm impriman es positiva eso significa
que la primera derivada está creciendo y
si la segunda derivada es negativa eso
quiere decir que la función repriman va
a estar decreciendo dicho de otra manera
si la segunda derivada va a cambiar de
positiva negativa eso quiere decir que
la primera derivada va a cambiar de
crecer a decrecer lo voy a notar así
decrecer
ha de crecer
crees
muy bien y ahora qué va a pasar con la
función por sí misma bueno podemos verlo
así si mi prima es positiva entonces la
pendiente está constantemente creciendo
y eso significa que tenemos una
concavidad hacia arriba lo voy a poner
aquí con cavidad
hacia arriba y bueno tenemos una
concavidad hacia arriba cuando la
segunda derivada es positiva pero cuando
la segunda derivada es negativa entonces
mi función va a cambiar a una concavidad
hacia abajo
concavidad hacia abajo
pero como solamente tenemos la gráfica
de g prima
entonces vamos a fijarnos en qué es lo
que tiene que pasar con qué prima y lo
que nos dice aquí es que nos vamos a
fijar en cuando mi prima cambia de
crecer a decrecer ok pues vamos a verlo
aquí estamos creciendo creciendo
creciendo creciendo creciendo llegamos a
este punto y después de este punto
déjame ponerlo así y después de este
punto empezamos a decrecer de crecer de
crecer después crecemos crecemos
crecemos crecemos crecemos y en este
punto otra vez
empezamos a decrecer y bueno así
seguimos ahora este no es el único caso
en donde tenemos un punto de inflexión
todavía no hemos acabado porque un punto
de inflexión lo encontramos en todos los
casos cuando un gen impriman cambia de
signo y en este caso tengo el cambio de
signo de positivo a negativo de una
función positiva a una función negativa
pero también hay otro caso en el caso en
que tengamos gente prima negativa lo voy
a escribir así me da
viva y que cambien ahora a positiva
o sí
y bueno eso quiere decir que prima cómo
se va a comportar bueno eso quiere decir
que eje prima va a cambiar de de crecer
a crecer y lo voy a poner así desde
crecer
crecer va a cambiar a crecer
así que fijémonos ahora en qué momento
que prima
cambia de crecer a crecer y para eso nos
vamos a fijar aquí aquí estamos
creciendo de crecemos y aquí cambiamos
de crecer a crecer así que aquí tengo
otro punto de inflexión aquí tengo otro
más y después crecemos crecemos crecemos
de crecemos y aquí otra vez cambiamos
desde crecer a crecer entonces estos
cuatro puntos son puntos de inflexión
que ya encontramos al menos de una
manera visual bien y si ahora vemos las
opciones y buscamos la respuesta a la
pregunta original que decía cuál es el
valor de x para el punto de inflexión
más a la izquierda de la gráfica de gel
bueno pues ahora puedes ver que es x
igual a menos 3 así que lo voy a poner
justo así esta es mi respuesta si
observas x igual a menos 1
también me da un valor de un punto de
inflexión x igual a 2 también me da el
valor de x de un punto de inflexión y
también de x igual a 4 de hecho todos
estos son los valores que toma x en los
puntos de inflexión pero que están más a
la izquierda es x igual a menos 3 en
este intervalo